[Musik]
u
hallo herr sie willkommen so sullivan
heute ist wieder ein super lakers
mittagsgericht und zwar werde ich ein
kaffee zubereiten mit brokkoli mit
kokosmilch gefällt mir ganz besonders
gut und auch eine murat wird später
glaube ich keine zeit begeistert sein
ich darf nicht verraten doch kein klub
mit drin steckt dann ist alles in
ordnung
ich zeige mich immer kurz die zutaten
das gericht geht auch super schnell das
heißt mal kurz nach der arbeit
zubereitet funktioniert wirklich super
dafür brauche ich zwei esslöffel sesamöl
eine zwiebel 1 knoblauchzehe und ein
stück ingwer zwei esslöffel rotary passe
eine doofe kokosmilch bisschen etwas 400
milliliter etwas wasser
jede gewürze salz pfeffer und gemalert
puma habe ich eine doofe abgetrocknet
ihrer ärzte sind etwas 240 gramm
abtropfgewicht millimeter zum
abschmecken populärer brauche ich etwa
750 gramm und habe ich noch weiß und von
dem ich da einen basmatireis ab 250
gramm und werde es auch zuerst den reis
zubereiten und weißem reis so ich mache
immer gerne bereit mit rot
das heißt ich gebe den teil reiss hier
rein und ich hab den vorhin diesem
wetter auch abgemessen
jetzt brauche ich einfach die 15 fache
menge an wasser und will einfach noch
mal eine menge und dann noch mal die
halbe menge und fahren jetzt etwa auf
250 milliliter ich mag ganz gerne wenn
etwas salz anreise zum beispiel mit rein
und dann gebe ich jetzt den deckel drauf
nach das ganze aufkochen und dann bei
niedriger stufe etwas 10 bis 15 minuten
quellen so bis eben die flüssigkeit
eingezogen
[Musik]
hier kann ich inzwischen bei thomas
friebe knoblauchzehe und sind immer fein
würfeln und das sehvermögen habe ich
bereits in einen roten kopf kleben und
erwärmen zwei mittel helfen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
gebe ich die gewürfelten zwiebeln was er
und delling was vom öl trennen ich jetzt
weil es einfach sehr groß wirklich auch
zur asiatischen gerichten passt und
wirklichen vor dem kräftigen geschmack
auf haben war das hier kurz angebraten
ist alles schön klassisch ist so wie
meine augen
[Musik]
in der zwischenzeit kümmere ich mich
jetzt um den brokkoli und fahrtraining
stil ab den besuch nicht aber gleich mit
aber es ist teil ist erstmal sind vor
kuli in seiner wolken und zwar direkt so
wie ich sie eben auch später in essen
haben ich möchte hier erst einmal ab und
dann zahle ich noch mal ein kleiner
[Musik]
einstimmig wenn ich jetzt hier unten
einfach erstmal den absatz arbeit und
dann schälen und kann ihn auch fein
würfeln den den kann man wirklich immer
mit verwenden
[Musik]
zu den themen geben kräftig kari passte
mir dazu und klassik auch kurz mit an
und dann kann ich die zwischenzeiten
commitments vögeln
denn die setzt immer gerne ab oben dann
die fettschicht unten das wasser und
trinken sollte der zuspruch am schlitten
dann wird das ganze wieder homogen aber
selbst auch nicht schlimm jetzt mit
homogenen werden würde
und spätestens im pop vermissten die
kokosnuss kommt hier rein
hier seht ihr auch der band los aber
sobald das ganze auf kocht wenn sie den
fernseher haben auch sobald es hier
gleich aufkauft verbinden vermischt wird
ganz gut und verbindet sich mit immer
kämpft
[Musik]
jetzt hab ich schön verbunden mit
duschen und dem wasser nicht reichen da
schaut er an dass zwischen 150 und 250
milliliter sind okay das ganze dass ich
jetzt auch kochen wird es aber vorher
natürlich noch mit salz pfeffer und
kurkuma hat ihr kein kurkuma hab ich das
gar nicht schlimm ich finde es bringt
einfach noch mal schöne eine schöne
farbe preis und vor allem ist eben oft
sehr gesund
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hier trifft aufkochen lassen und etwa
fünf minuten einkochen
[Musik]
das duftet schon mal richtig gut aber
wir wollen heute nicht zu sein denn was
fehlt ihr noch
chili ich nehme gleich zwei ziele die
kinder essen heute nicht mit die
menschen heute lieber bei oma es muss
also können wir das auch schön scharf
würzen mit chili und dann aber auch im
vergleich schon fertig
[Musik]
apropos links mit zum karin und den
nassen sand für etwas vier bis fünf
minuten mit wochen damit sie selber
entscheiden je nachdem wie weit ihn
haben möchte ich mag es eher werden
gemüse noch besser ab und dann muss ich
die kichererbsen eigentlich nur noch
dazu geben dann ist sicher mit
aufgewendet weil sie sind schon
eingetroffen
[Musik]
das gericht bereits fertig und ich muss
sagen ich hab schon probiert und das
schmeckt mir sehr gut
murat wird auch der beste sein da kommt
auch gleich nach hause sag ich mal wie
ich es immer gerne anrichte und waren
nämlich dafür so ein kleines café
es sollte nicht so groß sein denn es
soll hier auch keine grenzen mehr noch
was lernen
aber diese menge reichen wir ungefähr
für vier personen weniger und dann kann
man sich ja noch nach schaffen möchte
man konnte ja auch der vermieter oder
anderen rand hier kann ich jetzt schön
dafür aufgeben und martin brokkoli so
richtig gerne der es noch schön bissfest
und knackig nicht so weich gekocht wie
man den früher von der mama oder von der
oma vielleicht kennt dann haben wir
schon eine richtig lecker gesicht macht
mir noch ein bisschen die metten abbau
[Musik]
und das i-tüpfelchen ist dann noch ein
bisschen sesam und wo habt ihr schon
innerhalb von etwa 20 minuten ein
richtig leckeres hauptgericht und falls
ihr auch hunger bekommen habt und
missbrauch bekommen hat dann schaut es
nochmal ihre sessel und die flut hatte
auf meinem blog auffällig zloty an
ich muss dazu sagen für mich passte
hervorragend falls ihr es gar nicht so
scharf möchtet lasst den chili weg oder
nimmt man nur ein natürlich schultern
oder mal was zum beispiel eine halbe
post bei den meisten ganz gut und ich
wünsche euch jetzt schon mal einen
richtig guten appetit wir lassen es uns
hier auch gleich schmecken und bis zum
nächsten mal wird dann
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein